[Musique]
je vous renouvelle édition du 7 8
politique sûreté les filets invité
aujourd'hui olivier augustin le porte
parole de lutte ouvrière dans les
yvelines il défend les couleurs de
nathalie arthaud candidate crédité de
moins de 20% des intentions de vote
alors quels sont les enjeux du scrutin
pour ce parti quel rôle jouer ses
réponses dans un instant au cours de ce
rendez vous nous ferons aussi le point
sur la campagne des législatives qui se
préparent les candidats se manifestent
déjà dans les différentes
circonscriptions du département olivier
augustin bonjour je vous représentez
donc nathalie arthaud candidate
communiste elle se revendique comme tel
trotskiste également sa cime chaque fois
ces deux notions pour vous aujourd'hui
tornos et des notions très importante
c'est une carte d'identité à travers
toute notre toutou notre mouvement tout
ce que nous on à dire et là en
particulier à l'occasion des élections
présidentielles pour bien marquer notre
camp en tant que communiste en tant que
trotskiste en tant que révolutionnaires
aussi eh ben on tient à affirmer le camp
des travailleurs et à mettre vraiment la
priorité pour défendre les intérêts des
travailleurs
en ce qui concerne les problèmes de tous
les jours et compris bien sûr le chômage
les conditions de vie les conditions de
travail et les salaires et on tient
vraiment à marquer notre campagne en
défendant ce camp là et d'ailleurs nous
sommes les seuls vraiment à dire tout ce
qu'on dit justement à propos du chômage
qui en a ras-le-bol aujourd'hui que dès
qu'on parle des du chômage c'est pour
attaquer les chômeurs dès qu'on parle de
ce qui se met au niveau de la sécurité
sociale de tous ceux qui se mettent en
arrêt maladie c'est pour nous dire qu'on
serait trop malade ou même en ce qui
concerne les salaires ce serait pour
dire qu'on coûterait trop cher
eh bien nous on prend le contrepied de
toutes serrées de tous ces arguments là
pour mettre en avant notre politique et
pour mettre en avant l'intérêt des
travailleurs c'est notre priorité
on va venir sur quelques points du
programme vous avez mentionné aussi
cette notion de révolutionnaire je vais
lire un passage extrait de votre site
internet lutte ouvrière entend préparer
les travailleurs à s'organiser pour
affronter la répression mais aussi pour
imposer par la force s'il est besoin la
volonté est de la majorité de la
population à une minorité de possédants
ça veut dire tout est à dire quoi qu'il
faut une révolution il faut que le sang
coule de regarder non c'est pas ça de
toute façon le problème c'est que
leur indépendamment nous qui coule
aujourd'hui indépendamment de nous dans
pas mal de pays du monde
mais regardez pour revenir sur en france
ce qui s'est passé il ya moins d'un an
à propos des doigts et conneries il y
avait une majorité de la population
ouvrière salariés qui a été bien sûr
tous ceux qui sont privés d'emploi qui
était vraiment contre cette loi et
comrie et bien le gouvernement à passer
en force
pas simplement avec l'article 49 3 mais
aussi avec des désescalade rond de crs
dans toutes les manifestations
auxquelles des milliers voire même des
millions de salariés de travailleurs ont
participé
eh bien il a fallu se frotter contre les
crs et compagnie et bien c'est cette cet
état de choses que nous on dénonce bien
sûr nous faut absolument qu'on se
mobilise faut absolument qu'on que le
monde du travail
eh bien il dise ce qu'il a à dire est
qu'on est comme objectif pour revenir
sur le côté révolutionnaire des choses
de dire qu' il y en a il y en a
ras-le-bol que ce soit la bourgeoisie
que ce soit les capitalistes qui est la
main sur toute l'économie et qui décide
du jour au lendemain de vouloir de
pouvoir fermer une entreprise et de
mettre sur le carreau des milliers voire
des dizaines de milliers de salariés
comme entre autres par rapport à ce jour
une usine à qui un groupe quoi qui est
vraiment dans l'île de france aussi et
qui a mis sur le carreau en l'espace de
trois ans dix sept mille travailleurs
avec la fermeture d'aulnay mais pas
seulement
et en tout cas de nous ça on le dénonce
et cette violence là pour l'ours en est
une vraie violence que nous on condamne
et qu'on condamne bien sûr la politique
des patrons qui est de mettre au chômage
des dizaines parler de l'apport salariés
c'est que c'est quoi la bourgeoisie pour
bien clarifier ses éléments de langage
choisi
regardez autour de vous ben est en cours
arnaud seul il possède des milliards et
des milliards et c'est des gens qui
vivent du travail des autres et
s'enrichissent du travail des autres
c'est des gens qui s'accaparent
justement toutes les richesses que le
monde du travail et produits nous mêmes
en tant que travailleurs nous sommes à
la source de toutes les richesses que ce
soit de la table sur laquelle on ou des
sièges sur lesquels on est assis ou de
la table là qu'on a devant nous du
costume que vous portez des micros des
caméras et des télés c'est nous qui
sommes allés à la source et à la
création de toutes ces richesses à et
pourtant c'est nous qui n'en profitons
pas et c'est nous qui devrions nous nous
nous retrouver au chômage et qui
devrions accepter des salaires à moins
de 11 100 voire 200 euros à peine le
smig et bien ce monde là en tout cas
nous on ne conteste alors la grande
bourgeoisie bien sûr elle s'accapare et
un vol toutes ces richesses là pour
justement dans le remettre dans le monde
de la finance dans et faire qu'ils
gagnent encore davantage d'argent et de
plus en plus d'argent que vous croyez
aujourd'hui au processus électoral je
vous pose cette question parce que les
élections finalement lutte ouvrière il
croit pas vraiment pour nous c'est un
moyen d'exprimer un certain nombre
d'idées c'est un moyen de mettre en
avant notre programme et donc notre
programme et c'est là où il est
important mais bien sûr que pour faire
aboutir sa on compte pas sur les
élections pour nous c'est un programme
de lutte c'est pas un programme comme on
entend souvent d'autres candidats
électorale avec démesure où on prendrait
de l'argent ici ou faire un traficotage
de choses comme ça nous un programme de
lutte avec comme première mesure mais
vraiment la plus importante c'est
l'interdiction des licenciements c'est
la répartition du travail entre tous
sans perte de salaire l'augmentation
même du salaire et bien sûr 3800 euros
en salaire minimum avec une augmentation
bien sûr général de 300 euros parce
qu'aujourd'hui dans toutes les
entreprises dans lesquelles on est on
est confronté avec des salariés et
nous-mêmes a gagné quoi on 112 100 euros
et je vous promets que
moi je travaille ahronot chat donc dans
la région et je vous promets que pour
avoir un salaire de 1400 à 1500 euros ce
qui est à peine suffisant même pour
vivre et bien on est obligé de
travailler voire un ou deux samedis
supplémentaires par an par par mois et
on a à peine à s'en sortir alors que
1800 euros nets
bien sûr c'est le minimum pour pouvoir
payer son loyer ses traites et puis si
jamais on a des incidents avec sa
voiture ou d'autres est bien pour
pouvoir pallier à la moindre difficulté
mais c'est vraiment le minimum mais bien
sûr c'est une exigence du monde du
travail et aujourd'hui il est
intolérable de pouvoir se retrouver avec
des salaires vraiment au ras des
pâquerettes
comment se passe la campagne sur le
terrain aujourd'hui pour vous les
moments difficiles cette campagne
présidentielle quand simplement non il
n'est pas difficile nous on est content
d'engager des discussions on est content
de se retrouver sur sur les marchés à la
porte des entreprises dans partout là où
vivent nos camarades partout là où on
vit nous mêmes on est en contact avec
des dizaines voire même des fois des
centaines de personnes au fur et à
mesure des jours de la campagne pour y
défendre notre programme pourrait
défendre nos idées et l'accueil qu'on
reçoive il ya beaucoup de discussions il
ya beaucoup d'inquiétudes et surtout il
ya beaucoup de colère il ya beaucoup de
colère que un peu ce que je disais tout
à l'heure que de se voir nous mêmes
responsables de tous alors que c'est
nous mêmes qui qui produisons c'est
nous-mêmes qui sommes vraiment à la
source de toutes les richesses produites
et nous il faudrait encore une fois
qu'on fasse des sacrifices qu'on se
serre la ceinture
il faudrait travailler 39 heures payées
35 faudrait même accepté de travailler
jusqu'à 65 ans quand on les entend tous
ces candidats qui se présentent aux
élections et là il ya de quoi être en
colère en notre candidature la
candidature de nathalie arthaud c'est
pour expliquer cette colère là c'est
pour exprimer la colère du camp des
travailleurs en colère contre qui ne
s'exprime pas toujours dans les urnes on
va revoir le résultat tout de même de
2012 dans le département des yvelines
justement dans notre département
vous le voyez c'est difficile de
transformer cette colère dans les landes
pour lutte ouvrière c'est peut-être
difficile mais mine de rien 0,35 si je
vois bien 0,30 environ 200000 voir 220
mille personnes qui ont voté salariés
travailleurs qui ont voté pour pour
notre pour nos idées pour notre
programme et c'est pas simplement un
chiffre ça représente aussi si
l'ensemble de tous ses salariés la de
tous ces gens là qui ont exprimé leur
adhésion à notre programme est bien se
mettait dans les rues pour y défendre
justement les exigences du monde du
travail en ce qui concerne le chômage et
les salaires etc
eh ben ça ça représenterait vraiment une
force regardez ce qui se passe en guyane
en guyane il ya quinze jours ou trois
semaines ils se passaient pas forcément
grand chose hélas il ya eu d'un grand
mouvement de révolte un grand mouvement
de grève qui a mis dans les rues des
centaines de milliers de travailleurs de
300 400 milles et ben ça ça marque les
c'est ça qui peut faire avancer les
choses
et bien non on compte sur cette force là
sur cette force collective pour faire
aboutir ses revendications la et 200
mille travailleurs en colère
eh ben je vous promets s'apaisent
s'apaisent autres candidats crédités de
monde 20% des intentions de vote dans ce
scrutin c'est jacques cheminade 75 ans
diplômé de hec paris et de l'ena
candidats inclassable sur le terrain lc
équipe mène aussi la campagne le
reportage nicolas landry on se retrouve
juste après sur ce plateau pour arrêter
les politiques d'austérité
lecture notre lecture du soir
vous rappelez d'été plan d'aidé en 2010
campagne compliquée pour les soutiens de
jacques cheminade dans les yvelines
ils sont confrontés au manque de
popularité de leur candidat selon les
derniers sondages ils ne dépassent pas
la barre des 1% l'an née lui je ne
connais pas et puis bah je n'ai même pas
entendu parler je sais pas du tout donc
je vais juste dire déjà savoir mais je
ne connais pas puisqu'ils viennent m'en
parler et je vais documenté je veux dire
et gérer un peu plus sur sur un site où
je vais voir ce que ce qu'il a à
proposer et à dire quoi jasmine algérie
connu depuis pas mal d'années à travers
à travers les médias et c'est quelqu'un
qui a fait qu'un énorme des bonnes idées
mais malheureusement je pense qu'ils se
réveillent un petit peu trop tard avec
tout ce qui se passe actuellement au
sein des médias concernant pas mal d des
des candidats autre difficulté le vote
utile de plus en plus évoquée par les
électeurs je vais pas voter pour
monsieur chef des cheminots je vais
essayer de jeter je vais vous dire
pourquoi parce que j'ai très peur
concernant le programme plusieurs
mesures économiques sous le slogan
libérez les français de l'occupation
financière au lieu d'utiliser l'argent
des gens et l'argent de l'état pour
sauver les banques
on veut séparer la partie banque
d'affaires pour la laisser assumer ses
dettes tout seul sans la renflouer et
que l'état retrouve le moyen de
contrôler le que l'état retrouve le
contrôle sur sa monnaie pour financer
les politiques de développement en 2012
jacques cheminade avait recueilli près
de 0 3% des suffrages dans les yvelines
juste un mot olivier august 1 pour lutte
ouvrière on entendu dans ce dans ce
reportage les électeurs dire le vote
utile c'est important on a peur du front
national vous allez subir ce vote utile
en quelque sorte si vous le pensez
en tout cas moi ce que j'ai envie de
dire ce que le vote utile le seul vote
utile c'est voter pour son propre camp
et pour les idées de son de son camp à
savoir et encore une fois l'interdiction
des licenciements vraiment stopper
l'hémorragie du chômage et bien sûr pas
un salaire en dessous de 1800 euros net
et ça c'est vraiment ces idées là que
nous on a envie de mettre en avant le
vote utile et est le seul vote vraiment
utile pour la population c'est ça
maintenant si les électeurs se reporte
sur tel ou tel autre candidat
de toute façon
les autres candidats se situe ce
vraiment sur un autre terrain qui est
celui du du camp des patrons du camp des
capitalistes est vraiment ils sont
vraiment situé sur ce terrain là aussi
avoir des landes b 10 autres ont reçu et
dix autres quand bien sûr la campagne
présidentielle qui touchent quasiment à
sa fin la dernière ligne droite en tout
cas chacun a des candidats utilisent ses
dernières forces pour détailler des
points de programme emmanuel macron par
exemple un meeting vient de se tenir
récemment dans les yvelines consacrés
uniquement aux jeunes quel discours pour
les jeunes le reportage renouvelé pour
apporter de la jeunesse au sein de la
classe politique c'est le message
affiché par les jeunes avec macron un
mouvement dans marche un discours
séduisant pour plusieurs étudiants
yvelinois ce qui n'a convaincu c'est la
nouveauté et le fait qu'on écoute
vraiment les gens qu'on fait des
réunions où on parle tout le monde
s'écoute
il ya une vraie entente et les jeunes
comme les moins jeunes et de toutes les
catégories sociales on a notre place
dans le mouvement à la fois ils libèrent
l'économie tout en protégeant les
salariés avec l'allocation chômage
universel et pour les indépendants les
commerçants les entrepreneurs et c'est
une mesure du programme des manuels
macron destiné aux jeunes développer la
formation en alternance dans tous les
lycées professionnels
objectif favoriser l'insertion sur le
marché du travail les jeunes ce qu'ils
font l'avenir c'est ce qu'ils font les
métiers de l'avenir et on parle beaucoup
de transformations transformation
numérique transformation des emplois
intégration dans la mondialisation et je
pense que les jeunes ont leur mot à dire
sur ce sujet il ya une volonté de faire
de la politique différemment cette
politique différemment c'est d'abord
l'intégration de tous les citoyens
le renouvellement comporte c'est la
parité
ou qui sait leur nation les partis
politiques la probité en fait partie
également
et donc c'est effectivement une marque
de fabrique du mouvement en marche
étudiante en sciences politiques
capucine a décidé de s'engager dans la
campagne en septembre dernier son rôle
gérer l'utilisation des réseaux sociaux
le numérique un outil stratégique
important pour emmanuel macron le
mouvement des jeunes avec macron
revendique près de vingt mille adhérents
en france
l'électorat jeune pour lutte ouvrière
vous leur dites quoi qu'il faut se
mettre en colère que aujourd'hui on
considère qu'on est jeunes on a en a un
sur quatre est au chômage ou qui
galèrent de petits boulots en petits
boulots et à un moment donné faut que la
jeunesse ouvrière ben on emboîte le pas
des luttes et qu'il faut vraiment qu'on
encore une fois qu'on fasse entendre les
exigences par rapport au chômage par
rapport aux salaires et compagnie le
problème c'est que aujourd'hui c'est la
précarité des cons fini ses études pour
ceux qui ont la chance de faire des
études est passé soit des petits boulots
soit la précarité c'est soit des
périodes vraiment de grosses galères
cours est aujourd'hui le seul avenir que
cette société pourrait nous offrir c'est
ça et ça c'est inacceptable
et aujourd'hui c'est pour ça faut
vraiment vraiment obliger les grandes
entreprises entre autres mais aussi les
petites et moyennes entreprises à
embaucher et à faire que tous les postes
précaires tous les travailleurs en
intérim et c est bien plus à accéder au
moins un contrat de travail à durée
indéterminée ça c'est essentiel pour
pouvoir justement essayer de voir les
lendemains pour autrement puisque les
jeunes aujourd'hui il voit quoi nous
continuons cette émission avec notre
rubrique légal cheating
[Musique]
et pour cela j'accueille en plateau
nicolas qui est lovitz bonjour nicolas
on joue aujourd'hui avec les surligneurs
de l'université de versailles saint
quentin vous allez passer au crible
l'une des mesures phare de jean luc
mélenchon la france insoumise c'est
l'impôt pour tous on rappelle que ce
collectif des surligneurs ce sont des
universitaires qui utilisent la
faisabilité sur un plan purement légale
des propositions des candidats à la
présidentielle donc l'impôt pour tous
aujourd'hui l'impôt universel pour tous
les français c'était une proposition
déjà de jean luc mélenchon en 2012 il
appelait ça alors la taxation
différentiel le nom change mais la
mesure est la même le député européen
souhaite que tous les français même ceux
basés à l'étranger déclarent leur
situation au fisc hexagonal pour payer
ensuite éventuellement un impôt si le
pays d'accueil et fiscalement plus
avantageux que la france c'est pour jean
luc mélenchon un moyen de lutter contre
l'évasion fiscale
il expliquait sa mesure début janvier
sur rmc et bfm tv écoutez le vous êtes
français très bien vous payez vos impôts
où que vous soyez sur la planète comment
vous faites dans le pays où vous êtes
vous payez ce que vous devez au pays
c'est bien normal et puis vous le dites
au fisc français et le fils dit ah bah
ça tombe bien vous ne devez rien ou bien
il dit ah ben si vous aviez été en
france vous auriez payé plus donc vous
payez plus vous voyez votre part ou
moins voilà pour la proposition elle est
réalisable possible enfin entièrement
légal oui alors en dehors de l'union
européenne pas de pas de problème les
états unis le font déjà chez eux même si
là-bas beaucoup de moyens légaux
permettent d'y échapper
en revanche au sein de l'union
européenne jean luc mélenchon ne pourra
pas appliquer cette mesure de façon
généralisée ce sera ce serait au
contraire contraire aux traités
européens qui garantissent vous le savez
la liberté de circulation des capitaux
il devra cibler uniquement certains cas
écoutez à ce propos
vincent couronne fondateur des
surligneurs ce que peut faire mélenchon
s'est justifié cet impôt universel et
cette taxation pour des raisons de lutte
contre l'évasion fiscale
et ça c'est quelque chose que la cour de
justice de l'union européenne accepte
totalement mais le problème c'est que il
devra cibler que les cas de
vraiment où il ya un problème d'évasion
fiscale ou en risque de fraude fiscale
internationale
il ne peut pas faire un impôt totalement
universel il faudra que ça soit ciblée
sur ces cas là et donc concrètement si
jean luc mélenchon veut faire un impôt
universel pour tous les français il
devra alors sortir de l'union européenne
évidemment c'est un autre sujet beaucoup
plus vaste on va peut-être demander à
notre invité d'aujourd'hui je travaille
parce que déjà les impôts faudrait déjà
que ces grandes entreprises ait deux
paye être paye vraiment ce qu'elles
doivent au niveau des impôts qu'on voit
des grandes entreprises comme google ou
même comme total elf finale et c'est
justement ne pas payer et ne pas mettre
la main à la poche et ne pas payer tout
ce qu'ils doivent tout simplement à
l'état
ça c'est quand même révoltant d'autre
part payer des impôts ça voudrait dire
avoir un travail et avoir un travail
aujourd'hui c'est quand même le la
grosse galère pour plus de 5 millions de
salariés aujourd'hui qui sont privés
d'emploi
sachez quand même envie de mettre
l'action et sur la proposition de
dénoncer sur la proposition dans lequel
au fond qui a été détaillé sur cette
idée d'impôt universel problème c'est
déjà encore une fois que les grandes
entreprises au moins à payer ce qu'elles
doivent et déjà après on verra ce qui se
passe mais l'un veut les grandes
entreprises dans le programme de jean
luc mélenchon là c'est vraiment sa cible
on est allé les particuliers ce qui est
se regarder ces patients suisses
composition conseil justement ceux qui
ont pas mal d'argent et qui ont été
faire des placements en suisse et qui
sont revenus ensuite pour se mettre au
niveau de la loi de l'état français ils
sont revenus quand ils ont rapatrié
leurs somme d'argent etc en france mais
il y en a combien il y en a combien qui
l'ont pas fait et puis ça représente
combien d'argent il a cédé sommes quand
même monumental c'est des milliards
d'euros mais l'outil que je sais 80
milliards d'euros qui échappent
justement et qui manque cruellement dans
les caisses de l'état pour créer des
postes d'enseignants pour créer des
postes dans les hôpitaux pour créer des
postes dans les chemins de fer etc
partout là où c'est nécessaire pour la
vie de la collectivité et ce vol parce
que ça c'est carrément du vol bien sûr
c'est injuste et franchement c'est c'est
révoltant merci
nicolas l'émission se poursuit à présent
nous avons parlé tout à l'heure du vote
des jeunes des jeunes des programmes des
politiques envers les jeunes aujourd'hui
nous allons passer à notre chronique la
campagne vue paraît ce sera au tour des
personnes en situation de handicap
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors de chacune des émissions nous
allons donc à la rencontre des habitants
leur demander ce qu'ils pensent de cette
campagne aujourd'hui nous sommes allés
écouter les personnes en situation de
handicap leur demandez vous allez nous
dire ensuite ce que lutte ouvrière leur
propose sur la belge souffre d'une
banque quand je suis j'habite à maurepas
depuis ils ne se répare et 11 12
atteints de myopathie du type des
ceintures je vais déficit de la
prestation de compensation du handicap
et le plus en charge qui me permet
d'avoir des personnes 14 au 24 au second
tour et qu'un deuxième tour à tour je me
suis dit c'est dire que les personnes
handicapées était une charge pour l'état
par un de mes assistants de vie
d'ailleurs en ce moment c'est un peu
difficile de trouver du personnel
trouver de l'argent maintenant
aujourd'hui pour payer les coûts être va
payer le petit nation moi je suis encore
vivant parce que nous avons un système
de santé de vie sociale qui qui vaut le
coup qui me permet de rester vivant est
alors faite de grade
parce que là personnage ne va pas me
permettre de continuer de vie je
n'aurais plus personne pour s'occuper
noir et bien moi je vais vous dites off
jamais jamais vraiment entendu à un
téléviseur futur candidat futur
président couteau qui dit moi j'ai un
programme
voilà qui qui pourrait changer la vie
des personnes handicapées les personnes
en situation de handicap qui se sentent
tout le temps oubliées des propositions
et révoltant c'est révoltant
d'autant plus que les riches s exiler
existent il suffit de prendre 75
milliards là d'euros de dividendes à des
hauts niveaux du cac 40 de toutes les
entreprises qui sont cotées en bourse
les quarante plus grosses et bien c'est
l'équivalent de 75 milliards qui vont
être distribués aux actionnaires
et qui vont être après re plonger dans
le monde de la finance et donc à fonds
perdus vraiment et bats la totalité de
cette somme la cia était justement
diriger vers tous les personnes
handicapées il est travail et handicapés
vers tous ceux qui sont justement qui
ont eu des accidents de la vie vraiment
que les allocations handicap d'une part
et toutes les aides et le personnel au
service de tous ces gens là pour leur
permettre de pouvoir vivre une vie
dignement
parce que là on assiste vraiment un
délabrement de leurs vies à tous les
niveaux plus largement pour lutte
ouvrière il ya une médecine gratuite
aussi sur les problématiques de santé
l'idée c'est de faire une médecine
gratuite vient en récupérant l'argent
des groupes industriels des bien sûr et
cet argent là ils existent et il serait
bien mieux au service de toute cette
population là plutôt qu encore une fois
de pouvoir servir aux banques pour
financer quoi pour jouer ou au monde du
monopoly et au monde de la finance quoi
restent quelques minutes avant de
conclure cette émission et j'aimerais
qu'on s'intéresse maintenant à une autre
campagne le 3e tour en quelque sorte la
campagne des législatives puisque
l'élection va succéder à la
présidentielle très rapidement dès le
mois de juin lutte ouvrière sera aussi
représentée dans le département des
yvelines vous même vous serez candidat
une nouvelle fois vous l'avait déjà été
en 2012 candidat dans la troisième
circonscription une circonscription
détenue jusqu'à présent par la droite
henri guaino on est aujourd'hui le
député même s'il ne sera pas soutenue
par les républicains quelles sont vos
ambitions dans cette troisième
circonscription et que peut-être l'une
des plus difficiles du département
peut-être en tout cas dans laquelle il
ya des centaines de milliers de gens et
de travailleurs et auquel nous on
s'adressera aux quels nous on présentera
encore une fois notre programme le
programme de nathalie arthaud le
programme de la défense des intérêts des
travailleurs du camp des travailleurs et
encore une fois on mettra en avant et
bien sûr l'interdiction des
licenciements et on mettra en avant un
salaire minimum de 1800 euros la
répartition du travail entre tous et sur
tout et ça on n'en a pas discuté mais du
contrôle du contrôle des comptes des
grandes entreprises
parce que ça c'est vraiment une mesure
qui fait partie est justement de
l'ensemble de notre programme et qui est
indispensable c'est qu'on puisse savoir
où passe l'argent qu'on puisse savoir
qu'est ce que devient tel ou tel
somme d'argent et à qui il a été
distribué et pourquoi il peut servir
et tout ça ça nous mettraient vraiment
en lumière et bien le vol le vol de
toutes les entreprises là sur justement
toutes ces richesses là encore une fois
dont nous mêmes nous sommes à la source
et nous nous irons danser législatives
là pour affirmer ce camp sur les
différentes candidatures lutte ouvrière
vous serez présent dans l'ensemble du
département
bien sûr il y aura source candidats dont
les deux circonscriptions dédié à ses
oreilles seront présents pour lutte
ouvrière les différents candidats qui
commença à se manifester
on peut citer aussi dans la 11e
circonscription jean michel fourgous le
maire d'elancourt qui entend reprendre
son siège perdu aux dépens en tout cas
au profit de benoît hamon
le front national a aussi annoncé qu'il
y aurait 12 candidats dans chacune des
douze circonscriptions on imagine bien
évidemment que les résultats des
différentes formations vont varier en
fonction du résultat la présidentielle
ce sera le vrai test la présidentielle
aussi pour lutte ouvrière et s'est
ensuite bien sûr c'est pour nous c'est
encore une fois c'est une façon de
d'être au contact c'est une façon de
pouvoir discuter de pouvoir être présent
comme on l'est durant toute l'année mais
encore une fois aussi à travers ces
élections la présidentielle comme
législatives pour mettre en avant notre
programme pour vraiment mettre en avant
nos idées et défendre toujours notre
camp le camp des travailleurs
merci d'être venus pour cette édition du
7 8 politique et n'oubliez pas également
que vous pouvez voter par procuration si
vous n'êtes pas disponible pour vous
rendre directement aux ions de vous
pouvez voter par procuration c'est en ce
moment qu'il faut s'en occuper c'est la
fin de ce set 8 politique on se retrouve
bientôt sur tv fils vous pouvez noter
d'ores et déjà le 18 avril à 21h nous
vous proposerons un débat avec les
représentants des onze candidats à
l'élection présidentielle ils
reviendront sur le programme de leur
parti sur les enjeux de ce scrutin d'ici
là la campagne se poursuit et elle est à
suivre sur notre antenne
[Musique]